hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
today we have a cosmologists on the show
not just myself another cosmologists
Anthony Aguirre who you know I'm not
gonna be able to say this is giving you
a typical view of what cosmologists
think about because Anthony and I
actually are much more sympathetic with
each other in our views of what are the
important cosmological questions than we
are with other cosmologists out there
but that's okay it's my podcast Anthony
has recently written a wonderful book
called cosmological Cowen's where he
tries to introduce some of the
mind-bending features of our
cosmological universe through the device
of telling little Zen koans if you're
familiar with the idea of Akko on it's a
little story that is supposed to bend
your mind a little bit right make you
think about things that are apparently
paradoxical this is how the world works
the world itself is not paradoxical but
it can seem that way sometimes so
thinking about those paradoxes drives
you to interesting places and as a
cosmologists it drives you to think
about things like entropy and
information and what happened at the Big
Bang do we live in a simulation
questions like this so those are the
kinds of issues that Anthony and I
discuss in the podcast and we get to
interesting places because entropy and
information are behind things like the
existence of life in the universe why
you remember the past and don't remember
the future so do we live in a simulation
these become interesting questions for
human life as well as for studying the
universe and at the end we mentioned the
fact that Anthony has gone beyond
studying the universe to actually found
some organizations that worry about
human life and where it's going so it's
a very fun conversation you know we had
to sort of bite our tongues because we
wanted to rush forward because we know
our common background but I think that
we did a pretty good job of explaining
things let me remind everyone that this
is a podcast you can review it on iTunes
which we always love you can support it
on patreon and you can go to the website
to find all the show notes and
transcripts and things like that
preposterous universe calm slash podcast
thanks for all your support and let's go
[Music]
Anthony here a welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks it's great to be here so
you are a professional physicist
cosmologist but even with a little real
astronomy in your background theoretical
astrophysics anyway like non
cosmological stuff but you've written a
book of Cohen's
I'm not I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
that correctly but the little Zen
stories could you explain to us why
purportedly respectable cosmologists
would write a book of Zen koans
purportedly respectable yes well it
seemed like an interesting sort of tool
in the sense that what I really wanted
to write a book about were sort of the
those strange fun tantalizing paradoxes
that you run into as a physicist or as a
philosopher or just as a person who
likes to think about things I think
there's sort of nothing more fun in my
actual job as a working cosmologists or
physicist then coming across something
where you think well this is true and
this is also plainly true yet those two
things totally contradict each other or
this is true yet it totally can't be
true
and there you feel like you have sort of
a puzzling mystery and and I wanted to
get a sort of sense of that and and that
experience that I think we all have now
and then of kind of the weirdness and
and like perplexity of the universe
and also in a way that that kind of
attached the physics ideas you know and
concepts and and thinking to stories
because you know people are storytelling
creatures so so the Kohen I had some
experience with with reading books of
koans before and kind of had a sense of
what they were about and a friend
suggested it's to me a Cohen is sort of
this device that's both kind of a story
kind of a like a fable or a tale that
encapsulate some idea in this case but
also kind of a confrontation like you
you should feel like why do I don't
quite know what that's about or where am
i with this after after reading the
Cohen but then you go on and kind of
delve deeper into it and so the point is
that being
cosmologists much like being one of
these students being upgraded by the Zen
master where the role of the Zen master
is played by the universe in this case
yes that that's the experience that that
I certainly have is a cosmologists and
as a physicist you know that you are
constantly forced in this place of being
bewildered or you're not doing your job
right I think I mean that's where the
fun is
I mean I sometimes tried to make the
point that you know people sometimes
object to this or that cosmological
theory because it doesn't feel right or
it's disturbing or whatever and I have
to ask why that should be a criterion
for anything at all I think that's right
I mean it's a tricky thing because you
know on the one hand physics you know
when you learn how the universe is it
often violates your intuition that you
had before but then you as a working
scientist generate a new set of
intuitions that go along with the
understanding that you've attained and
it you really believe in so it's always
that that tricky you know is this
violating my intuition because it's not
right and I've built up an intuition
that is a good guide to what's true and
what's not
or is it violating it because I'm still
stuck in some old erroneous intuition
that I've just inherited from wherever
that's not always easy to tell yeah
because physicists definitely do and in
fact should use some kind of intuition
right like not all theories are created
equal we have a feeling that something
is on the right track all the time and
it is as you said very very hard to
convey that feeling or even to defend it
in a court of law that's right so why
don't you start us off by giving us an
example if we could pick your favorite
go on or at least a good introductory go
on from your book which is called
cosmological Cowen's okay well let's see
do you want me to read one or just give
you a three ones do you do your dramatic
interpretation a dramatic interpretation
okay this one let's see the I'm trying
to decide between the the more Zen one
or the more yeah let's see this one this
one is called the cosmic now and it goes
like this takes place here now this so I
should say that the the
most of these things are kind of part of
a story that takes place in the early
17th century so this this one is an
exception in that it takes place right
here and now wherever that is
and here it goes it says right now as
you read this a baby in India is taking
its first breath and an old woman her
last a young woman and her love are
sharing their first kiss lightning
flashes across a dark sky the wind blows
through the hair of a solitary hiker in
the Sahara Desert a satellite is seeing
the Sun rise above the earth
a hurricane is blowing endlessly through
the college of Jupiter two rocks are
colliding just now in the third ring of
Saturn the new year is arising on a
planet around a star in our galaxy
perhaps the world has inhabitants who
are celebrating our galaxy moves about
100 miles closer to our neighbor
Andromeda toward their collision and
Union billions of years from now a star
in a distant galaxy ignites a Titanic
supernova explosion that ends its
hundred million year lifetime at the
same time hundreds of new stars first
ignite the observable universe adds
enough space for a hundred new galaxies
all of this is happening this very
second across the universe right now and
yet this right now across the universe
does not exist I mean as a straight
forward Western scientist I want you to
say what do you mean it does not exist
the point of this one I do know what you
mean of course but you don't know what I
mean of course but but the point of this
you know so we learned from Einstein's
special relativity that this idea that
there is a single moment of now across
the universe a single meaningful time at
which you say this was the past before
this time and it is the future after
this time that that exists for an
individual like here and now observer
like you experience a past in a future
in a now but such a thing doesn't have
an objective sort of existence across
the universe
that's what relativity tells us is that
if I attribute some moment of now sort
of spread out in in space someone else
can attribute an equally valid one sprat
down in space that is different from the
one I have and so the so there's a lot
of
sort of reasoning behind that and where
that that sort of truth arises from
relativity but but I think the point
here in you know in telling it that way
was to try to really bring that into
that sort of relativity truth which
physicists pretty much all accept now
and is in a sort of part of the standard
Canon of physics into its kind of
violent clash with your intuition
because your intuition is just screaming
at you like even if something's far away
it's either hasn't happened or it has
happened that there's the truth of the
matter and by sort of putting yourself
in that mind of envisioning all these
things happening at farther and farther
distances I think it sets up how very
strange that really is and you know even
as a physicist you get used to thinking
oh there's no absolute now and that's
fine and you know the equations aren't
everything but when you really think
about it like that is really really very
strange there's a little bit of a
tension I want to sort of restore your
reputation as a respectable cosmos by
talking about cosmology but I love this
idea of using the Cohens because there's
a bit of a tension between the
presupposition of scientists that the
role is ultimately logical and
intelligible and the what I take to be
the spirit of the Cohens which is that
sometimes maybe it's not sometimes maybe
you should give up on the hope of making
sense of everything do you think that
that's something to take into mind
yeah it's sorry I think it it's
interesting how different some of these
different questions and confrontations
play out in different ways so there
certainly are a good number where
there's something puzzling like you know
the fact that that a wooden and an iron
ball fall at the same rate and yet
there's a there's an elegant and in fact
beautiful explanation for why that is in
physics and once you understand it you
think wow that just really explained
that nicely yeah and and so there you
really you know it was puzzling but then
there's an explanation and you really
have it and you feel good about that
there are other ones where you feel like
there probably is an explanation but we
don't know
it is yet but we probably will get one
and we'll feel good about it afterwards
the you can em like things like quantum
gravity for example it's very confusing
how that how that is going to work but I
think we will have a theory of it at
some point and we'll feel good about it
but I think there is a class of
questions where it's not clear whether
the question is flawed or whether it's a
sort of unknowable answer you know when
you ask things like about probabilities
in an infinite universe and things like
that that are you just don't quite know
if if you've you're posing what feel
like like well posed questions but
you're getting sort of ambiguous answers
and you and it becomes rather unclear in
your mind is this actually a well posed
question or do I have to sort of uh nask
the question as sums anyone's asked you
to do but if it's not that question what
is it you know it becomes very unclear
what is the right question to ask so I
think there's somewhere I think we don't
know what the right question is or
whether the questions make sense and
then there are some where you feel like
you're really asking a totally sensible
question and just have no idea what the
answer is or if we'll ever know like it
with you with the right view of
interpreting quantum mechanics right it
feels pretty solid like I feel like I
understand what the issue is and just
don't know and and Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday I believe one thing and the
other days the other thing oh don't
worry I have a book coming out of that
without that that will fix all the
problems and make everyone agree
favoring the mystery for the next few
years savor the mystery you have a
couple months to savor the mystery good
but the one of the wonderful things
about the physics side of this so I take
your point that there are questions that
we by our intuitive lights or our folk
way of looking at the world make perfect
sense to us but maybe our experience
with the universe teaches us that we
should uh nask them but the point is
we're forced into that right we untried
our best to understand the universe as
it is and we're driven to these crazy
ideas about it like there's no such
thing as now so why don't we ground our
a little bit in the universe even you
mentioned relativity Einstein's general
relativity is the centerpiece of modern
cosmology give us your short take on
what what are the observational
established facts about the universe
that we're gonna have in the background
as we start speculating a little bit
well I think in terms of well there's
there's gravity and there's cosmology
and of course those are those are
intimately tied together and that
Einstein's gravity gives us the
mathematical framework to finally
describe you know the universe as a
whole that was something that wasn't
really possible to do very nicely before
we had Einstein's theory but now we do
and and so we can understand that the
universe that we see that we can
directly observe is expanding and has
been for the last 13.8 billion years and
is more or less uniform on large scales
and there there's this set of
astronomical and cosmological
observations that have been fit together
into this just remarkably explanatory
sort of model the standard cosmological
model that that happened you know during
our lifetimes we were we were witnesses
and at some small way a part of this and
it's really quite astonishing how
successful that is like the standard
model of particle physics that the real
challenge is finding something that
doesn't get explained reasonably well by
it right yeah there are times for
theorists when your theory is doing too
well that's right that's right it's
really fun for a while and then you you
get really good answers to a lot of
questions and pat yourself on the back
and suddenly realize that you've made
your job really hard because once you
have a really good theory it's there
there are always lots of things sort of
unexplained in detail like how galaxies
form in detail and and you can spend a
lot of fun time and energy understanding
that process better
but there's that's a different question
from are there things that are sort of
at fundamentally at odds with or sort of
have no viable explanation within the
cosmology and and we still have those
things in the form of dark matter and
dark energy in the sense you know that
we don't
really know what those things are but we
do know their properties quite nicely
and once you suppose these few
properties you explain an awful lot so I
I think a it's interesting that for a
book like this one or door just for a
topic with it you know that the the
whole universe which is you know
ultimately quite mysterious in a lot of
ways that that we've nonetheless come so
far in understanding and quantitative
detail on the very largest scales we can
observe and every time scale that we can
observe we have a pretty consistent
picture of that okay but share with our
listeners what the actual statement of
the standard cosmological model is how
Big Bang looks at any universe dark
matter dark energy that stuff yeah so so
the universe started actually I did one
of my rules by by talking about the
start of the universe when ya didn't
want to say anything the the part of the
universe that that we observe 13.8
billion years ago was an ultra hot
plasma nearly uniform expanding filled
with a tiny bit of normal matter baryons
protons and neutrons and electrons and
some contribution of dark matter and
some contribution very small of dark
energy and since then that expanding gas
is cooled and rarified the it was nearly
uniform so the non-uniformities in that
gas grew by self-gravity into large
complicated structures like now galaxies
and clusters of galaxies and within them
stars and planets and things meanwhile
the universe went through several
transitions where in the beginning it
was more or less a dominated by just
radiation light as time went on that
transitions into being dominated by
matter and now we're in this period
where the overall sort of expansion of
the universe is dominated by this
mysterious dark energy energy associated
with empty space and so we we have this
picture of a nearly uniform expanding
universe that is of all
all of DIN time that has kind of an
early middle and late phase to it we're
kind of in the middle phase and a sort
of explanation for where the the
structures that we see from galaxies
down to planets and even the origin of
of kind of the elements that we that
things are made of we have a sort of
origin story for all of those different
things within this cosmology again
details not work out but broad brush
kind of understanding in place so can I
make a controversial claim right off the
bat here yeah I don't think dark energy
is that mysterious I think that we'd
like to describe it that way but if we
think about dark matter
think about dark matter and dark energy
and I want you to explain a little bit
more of what those are and why we know
that they're there but um there's a lot
of different candidates for what the
dark matter is you know in an
information theory theoretic point of
view the entropy of dark matter is high
in the sense that we don't know what it
is whereas we kind of know what the dark
energy is it's a cosmological constant I
would put greater than 90% odds on that
it's the energy inherent to empty space
itself so I think we should stop calling
dark energy mysterious was surprising at
the time in 1998 when we found it but we
probably know what it is unless there's
some big surprise coming up in the
future I certainly agree that dark
matter is sort of unexplained but not at
all
particularly mysterious and that there
are lots of candidates and as you say
why should everything the universe is
made of happen to interact with light
and in ways that make it not dark matter
I've actually I'm on record predicting
that there will be multiple kinds of
dark matter and an old that actually has
started coming true right if you count
neutrinos and we can imagine you know
they are you gonna claim neutrinos if
that as a victory for your I'll take it
is I'll take it as a tiny little bit of
datum but a real victory would be
multiple sort of interestingly different
ones anyway I had I think it's riii
agree that I would put good odds against
dark energy being anything other than a
vacuum energy cosmological constant
the mystery I think as you point out is
not that there is such a thing but that
the mystery is how to make sense of its
value and what that tells us about the
Constitution of the universe as a whole
in that the the natural value for the
energy associated with empty space is
absolutely not zero there's no
particular reason to think it's zero
there was a time when we could imagine
that there would be such an argument and
and people search for that but they
never came up with a good one and then
we realized that that argument would be
wrong whatever it was yeah because it is
not zero I've made arguments I was very
firm in my convictions you could have
won a lot of money off of me
in the early 1990s if you would bet me
about the whether there was a vacuum
energy or not from a lot of people yeah
and anyone a lot of money could have
been collected from lots of people in
goo including me I think so
in fact since I read the first paper
that I wrote was trying to disprove the
cosmological constant observations
you're worse than me okay good so I'm
with you but the natural value for it is
some absurdly large number like like
characteristic of the Planck scale or
the supersymmetry scale or something
like that they're just absurdly larger
than the value that we observe let's
just be kind to our listeners and tell
them what it is in this sense well you
wouldn't so what do you mean when you
say cosmological constant so it is the
energy that you have when you say that
there are no particles in some region of
space so what's important to to keep in
mind is that when you say a photon a
particle of light what you really are
talking about is an excitation of the
electromagnetic field and if you say
there are no photons that means there
are no excitation x' but the field is
still there and the same thing with any
other particle electrons or protons or
quarks or whatever those things are
excitations of fields that are still
remain in place just you say that
they're in there unexcited or vacuum
state if there are no particles around
but there's no particular reason to
think that that unexcited state has zero
energy with it any more than you know if
you have an ocean and there are some
waves and if that are excitations on the
surface of the ocean
you might have an unexpected a shion's
there's still these fields around and
there's no particular reason to think
that the energy per unit volume the sort
of density of energy in the fields is
zero so so if you take away the
particles there still might just be
energy and that's what we call vacuum
energy and that's what we purportedly
measured back in 1998 because it made
the universe accelerate exactly and so I
think the other the last thing we're
gonna start speculating about the edges
of the observable universe pretty soon
so let's just remind the audience that
we are in fact respectable empirically
based scientists and explain why we
think there is dark matter what the
difference is between dark matter and
dark energy I think that there's still a
lot of people out there probably not
mindscape listeners but you know out
there in the world who think that dark
matter is just cosmologists covering up
for their mistakes and there's probably
something much simpler behind it all yes
so it there was a time when the the
reason to think that there was dark
matter was because galaxies didn't have
the dynamics you would expect given them
the stars that you can see in the and
the gas that you can see in the galaxies
so you would say here's a basically a
spinning ball or disk of stars and gas I
can see how much stars and gas there are
I can use Newton's laws to tell me how
the their motions should be given
Newtonian gravity and that mass and I
see that their motions are not actually
like that they seem to the motion seems
to indicate that there's more mass there
that you can see in the stars and gas
and if that was the only thing that that
you saw you a reasonable thing would be
to say well there maybe there's
something that you don't see another
reasonable thing would be to say well
there might be something wrong with
those laws of gravity on in this new
regime that you've explored so back in
the early 20th century there was a
discrepancy like this with the orbit of
mercury people postulated that there was
some ex
straw dust clouds or something in the
unit in the in the solar system that
caused this this perturbation in the
orbit of mercury that wasn't accounted
for by Newtonian gravity turned out
Newtonian gravity was wrong and this was
one of the pieces of evidence for
Einstein's relativity so so it could be
that such a thing was an indication that
gravity is wrong but this has become not
a really viable explanation for dark
matter anymore so at the time when it
was just about galaxies it's long gone
we have observations of galaxies
clusters of galaxies gas clouds
throughout the universe the so-called
microwave background radiation that
tells us how gravitate gravity related
to sort of variations in the density of
radiation and matter in the very early
universe we've got all kinds of
different gravitational lensing there's
like all kinds of different pieces of
evidence all of which are explained by
one assumption that there is this dark
matter which is a gravitating but
otherwise non interacting component to
the universe with like five or six times
as much density as normal matter protons
and neutrons and electrons once you make
that assumption all of these things are
explained very very elegantly
quantitatively on the other hand if you
try to explain it away with modifying
gravity or come up with a viable theory
of gravity that is different and
explains all these things it's
extraordinary daily difficult to do that
and I think there just isn't anything
believable at this point that that
doesn't also even have Dark Matter in it
yeah for the cosmic microwave background
radiation in particular I think it's
essentially impossible to do it without
invoking dark matter yes so good so we
have a universe we have a standard
cosmological model another one of these
terribly dry and boring names for a
magnificent edifice yes and it does a
pretty good job of explaining the
universe for the last 13.8 billion years
from the beginning of these herbal
University today so I want to talk about
both the far far pass to the big bang
and maybe even before but also the
future let's go to the future first like
what
it happens is the universe gonna wreak
elapsed is it gonna expand forever what
are your feelings here yeah this site I
think there's kind of only one thing
that this really depends on which is
whether the dark energy changes so it's
so if it really is a fixed cosmological
constant like like you and I would both
bet that it is then the future looks
pretty boring at least in the local and
region but boring on a very long time
scale I mean I think it has to be kept
in mind that although you'll hear that
sort of the although dark energy is kind
of taking over the dynamics of the
universe as a whole now and it's going
to make astronomy and extra galactic
cosmology kind of boring within the next
10 billion years or so we'll start to
just see many many fewer galaxies out
there near us
nonetheless the the piece that is
attached to us and will will sort of be
in our observable universe for for the
long term because it's gravitationally
bound to us still has just trillions and
trillions of years to go so so I think
there's a there's a very big future you
know in some sense we're sort of halfway
through the the age of the universe in
that the the kind of characteristic age
of the universe is in the 10 billion
year range and so we're kind of
middle-aged in that sense but but
there's a really really really long
retirement package you know the country
the universe is just many many trillions
of years depending and and depending on
what sorts of kind of energy sources you
you think that we might exist around
whether it's long lived low mass stars
or more exotic things like black holes
it could be just exponentially long
times that we have ahead of us so it's
it's a it's a slightly strange thing
that we're in that the universe just
will go on for so long I think and so
and what explain a little bit about the
dark energy not going away so I think
that's something kind of mysterious I
mean ordinary matter dilutes away but
dark matter doesn't
dark energy does dark energy doesn't
sorry I'm gonna get my gonna be kicked
out of the club
[Laughter]
yeah that is in fact it's its
characteristic attribute is that it
doesn't go away when you make the space
bigger because it's associated with
empty space if you if you make empty
space twice as big you just get twice as
much of it rather than it being sort of
in the numerator like you have an amount
of stuff divided by an amount of space
here you have an amount of space divided
by an amount of space and just nothing
nothing changes so so it is it it's a
strange substance and it allows I mean
we'll talk about this presumably but one
of the really neat things about dark
energy is that it it just seems to cheat
a little bit in that it's you take this
amount of dark energy and you let it
expand which it wants to do because the
other property of this stuff is that it
forces sort of an expansion of
space-time it causes a repulsive force
that pushes space-time apart so it wants
to expand and in doing so it makes more
of itself so it's kind of this endlessly
self-creating substance that that I
think has no real analog outside of you
know there are metaphors you can make
but I think there's nothing else really
like it at least in the physical world
maybe there are things in economics that
are but does not violate conservation of
energy like I'm sure this is what people
are thinking right now
yeah and that that is one of the most
fascinating things is how and maybe we
should we should get to talking a little
bit about the the early universe because
this is this is one of the the coolest
stories ever I think it's how all of
this stuff that we see can in principle
without violating anything come from
almost nothing so so there's a there's a
story I think that the that's just an
amazingly fascinating one that we've
built up where you can start with just a
tiny little bit of this vacuum energy
and that vacuum energy wants to make
more of itself so it so it expands and
creates a large volume with lots of
energy associated with it so it's
created all this energy and you think
well wait a minute it's creating energy
but energy conservation is a tricky
business especially in
general relativity so there are
different stories I think you can tell
as to how this make sense one story I
think you can tell which I think is not
a bad story is that let me just let me
just butt in to say that you know ya
when we say stories you can tell these
are all stories that are translated from
the original math right so there is the
math is absolutely crystal-clear and the
only question is what are the best words
to attach to it to make ourselves feel
better well it's mostly crystal-clear in
this case I think as you agree so
there's something that's totally clear
which is that energy can be positive or
negative and and so zero can be a sum of
a big positive number and a big negative
number so at least in principle you can
imagine I can take something with zero
energy and turn it into some combination
of positive and negative energy stuff
and that's a useful way I think of
looking at this process where gravity
provides negative energy so if you have
a gravitational attraction between two
objects and put them on a scale the two
objects together will weigh just a
little bit less very very very little
less than the two objects weighed
separately because the gravity between
them actually has negative energy and
that counts as mass and so they have a
little bit less mass when close together
and you can imagine the YouTuber is held
because it would take energy to pull
them apart it would take energy to pull
them apart yes and you can get a little
bit under energy out by letting them
move together so it's and the universe
plays this trick so in contemporary
cosmological models the universe just
ruthlessly exploits this trick to create
a just massive amount of positive stuff
and negative gravitational energy that
exactly compensates it balancing the
books nicely with zero energy to the
entire universe and this totally feels
like cheating but it's not a does you
know it's totally allowed by the
mathematics and I think when you have
something that has such a surprising and
sort of elegant explanatory power but
also is just totally what the math tells
you is allowed but completely violates
your intuition that that I think is a
fun thing but when you say we're so sure
that nothing can come out of nothing or
that you can't have a whole bunch of
stuff coming out of nothing
and yet physics just tells you exactly
how you can do exactly that that's a
great thing to learn yes so not only is
it okay if the universe expands and
there seems to be more and more vacuum
energy but the whole universe could
potentially have exactly zero energy and
therefore be the kind of thing that
could exist or not exist without
violating conservation of energy right
all right so tell but I do want to get
there I mean it's up to you though I
want to ask you about the future because
you painted this big picture and I want
to know exactly how bleak it is you know
the Stars so not only are you know where
the Sun is gonna burn out as nuclear
fuel that's a matter of a few billion
years but everything's gonna go away
right all the other galaxies are gonna
disappear every everything that isn't
bound to us at the moment is going to
disappear yeah so so that region of the
universe it will be sort of connected
together will be sort of limited now I'm
gonna assume as I think probably should
be assumed but we don't really know that
that no faster than light travel or or
wormholes left over from the Big Bang
that we can sneak between or through are
going to exist so we really will be
limited by the speed of light so that so
that means that you know our descendants
or whatever is in our galaxy looking
around billions of years from now will
have just a smaller sort of set of stuff
to play with than we do in the sense
that they will they won't be able to go
to visit other galaxies and come back to
report or even reach some of those other
galaxies on the other hand if we if you
were to imagine you know humanity
cracking out into the galaxy and even
going to neighboring galaxies and and
continuing to go to neighboring galaxies
that there's a great deal of stuff that
we could eventually inhabit so I think
you know starting now is is essential in
this program so if we're thinking big
everything in the galaxy is gonna fall
into a black hole and eventually
evaporate away in the long term yeah in
the very long term it
and I gave a name to these sort of
timescales in the book of culpas which
is which is ten to the like three digit
number or ten to the tenth or this to
the multiple digit number so these are
sort of time scales that are so long
that they sort of make every other time
scale that we care about ridiculously
short in comparison to them so yes I'm
those sorts of timescales
there's there's a pretty bleak future I
guess I feel you know if if the question
is is this a cause for sort of some sort
of exponential despair I don't know
really I think what the universe will
look like an hour
sort of conceptualisation what will be
possible technologically you know a
thousand or a million let alone you know
a trillion years from now I I think it's
a despite my faith that we really have
understood
lots of fundamental things about the
universe I want to have a little bit of
humility and and suggest that there may
be lots more to it that even us great
cosmologists still don't understand well
okay that's interesting because you know
I want to be more hubristic I guess than
you in the following sense
the universe is going to keep emptying
out and as you said you know some things
are gonna be bound together so if it
weren't for certain factors you could
imagine like that the earth would remain
existent for infinity years right even
though there's other galaxies far away
that we would lose sight of but I think
that there are other factors I think
there's things like the second law of
thermodynamics which I know you're also
a big fan of I think that life requires
a source of low entropy in order to keep
going and that's sort of a buzzword
Laden sentence and maybe unpack it but I
think that if you believe that then
eventually we'll be done there'll be no
way to for life to continue to exist
forever
yeah and then in this so I think that
that's sort of the the classical view of
the so-called heat death of the universe
that we reach this kind of maximum
entropy state and and I think that
that's probably true it's
level but I think there are a lot of
subtleties to these questions that you
know once you delve into them so when
you you know so I do wonder and this is
something that I think is worth talking
about whether well yeah maybe maybe
maybe it's worth backing up a little bit
in saying talking about what the second
law of thermodynamics means and and is
and what entropy is because I I think
that what you're you know the idea that
entropy will sort of run its course and
will come into equilibrium and then
nothing interesting will happen again is
probably true but at the same time we
also knew that somehow the universe
started with this tremendously low
entropy and tremendously large amount of
information we have no explanation for
how that happened and it could be that
once we understand if there is an
explanation for that if we were to
understand it it might shed new light on
that long-term question about the future
as well
what would you might say this is that
there's no explanation that everyone
accepts I've been proposed explanations
I think they're yes there are there's no
explanation I think that has the air of
convincing this that for example the
explanation for all the stuff came from
so I think there's two sort of
fundamental mysteries if you talk about
ultimate origins where did all this
stuff come from
and where did all the information come
from because a way to think about low
entropy is lots of information so the
universe sort of started out with this
huge endowment of matter and also this
huge endowment of information and and
we're sort of both of those things are
still around the information is a little
bit different in that in some sense it
and what in some description and we can
get into this it gets used up the second
law in entropy increases and the
information is kind of going away
whereas the matter kind of sticks around
although in less and less useful forms
in some sense but at any rate the
universe started out with this huge
endowment of each which is the
foundation of everything in exists in
the universe now the stuff forms the
galaxies but the information allows the
galaxies
form and allows all kinds of entropy
increasing processes which are every
interesting process to occur otherwise
we would just be in this very boring
equilibrium state when we're sort of
nothing interesting happens so there in
those twin mysteries of origins I think
we have actually a pretty good
explanation on the stuff side you know
the one that we discussed that you can
get it all out of nothing and we have
descriptions for where the different
kinds of stuff came from where the
baryons came from there at least
candidates for them whether but I think
we have no such convincing explanation
as to where all the information came
from other than sort of just assuming
that it was there I think so we should
dig into a little bit more the relation
what entropy is what information is and
how they related because I think that if
you tell people that there is a lot of
information in the early universe
they're gonna think that there were a
lot of hard drives and books and things
like that so clearly you mean something
slightly different than that right right
and it's not like that and it's and it's
feels paradoxical also because the you
never Li universe was so boring and
simple and yet we say that there was a
lot of information to it so so this is
we're talking about it and what's
difficult to talk about with entropy is
is that people entropy is a very
dangerous term in that people even
professionals say it to each other
meaning quite different things
and when they tell each other oh I mean
this sort of entropy or that sort of
entry then they understand each other
but nonetheless it's a complicated term
so so I would the way I think of it I
think of entropy as being two rather
distinct concepts that that people call
entropy and that that can be connected
so one concept of entropy might be
called sort of randomness that if you
have a set of possible ways a system can
be you say it's got these different
states that it can have but you don't
know which one it's in see you you have
some ignorant for some reason about what
state the system is in you can assign
probabilities to the different states in
the system is in and entropy is kind of
a measure of how uncertain you
about about those states so if the if
the system is in exactly one state and
you know that then you would assign zero
entropy to it there's sort of no
randomness to it you know exactly what
it is if you assign equal probability to
every one of the states like you have no
clue what state the system is in then
you would say that's maximum entropy and
that's sort of you could say that that's
equilibrium though I think that's a
slightly different way of thinking about
it so that's sort of for the air in the
room for example given that it's all
spread out I have no idea where any
individual molecule is and that's high
entropy but if I knew it was all hiding
in the corner if all the air was in one
corner I would know something about each
individual molecule oh it had that
information yes but I'd like to so so
these concepts are related but I think
you're getting into the second
definition of entropy that I'd like to
come to after so so I think again there
are relations between them but I think
they're two conceptually somewhat
distinct things one is kind of how much
you don't know about the the state of
the room and this is very directly
connected to information in the sense
that when you learn something about a
system you have information about it so
if I say I don't know anything about the
room or I don't know anything about the
system equal probability for anything
but then I go and make a measurement and
I say ah you know it's not in these
states over here it's in these so let me
assign zero probability to those states
that I know it isn't and greater
probability to the ones that I know it
is then I've changed this entropy the
entropy is now lower for the system that
I would assign to it and I have
information about it and so I can a
useful way to think about information is
the difference between the entropy or
the randomness entropy that a system has
and the maximum possible randomness
information entropy that it would have
and this you can you can show that this
is exactly what we mean when we say you
have like four bytes of information or
something like that that you can
correspond those exactly so that's one
one sort of information theoretic sense
of entropy and this is used all the time
talking about communication and computer
processing and all sorts of things where
we talk about bits of information it's
exactly that concept now there's another
concept which is the one that that you
just alluded to
which is to say there's a whole bunch of
states that a system might have but I
want to label them in different ways
that are of interest in me so I might if
I were in a kitchen say there are lots
of different ways that my kitchen might
be but some of them are clean and some
of them are like not quite so clean and
some of them are pretty messy and some
of them are super messy and so I could
give each state that the kitchen might
possibly have one of those labels and
what I would find is that they're just
in general if you're a normal person
very very few clean States the kitchen
can have relative to how many dirty
states the kitchen can have and this is
a rather different thing that you know
we're choosing these labels physicists
would call them macro States and
assigning each state the kitchen can
have each detailed state the kitchen you
can have for one of these macro states
now what you then find is sort of
evidently if you if you then move the
kitchen from one state to another more
or less at random like it like you just
go and putter around in the kitchen or
you let your kid make a meal or
something they will randomly move the
state of the kitchen from one state to
another and because there are lots more
dirtiest States than cleanest States it
will tend to become dirtier and dirtier
that is the the kitchen will just wander
into a state of more dirtiness because
there are many many more of them so this
sense of entropy which you might call
like generic nests or like disorder or
something really is a little bit
distinct in that it has to do with the
way that for some reason we label these
the the actual states of the kitchen
into these macro States or these
collections which have very very
different sizes and and those
collections for sort of summaries for
our use of oh it's useful for me to call
with all these states clean and all
these dirty for some reason now what's
what's interesting about these two
notions of entropy is that one of them
has a second law and is the thing that
we talk about when we talk about the
second law of thermodynamics that's the
second
one the first one if I just say here the
states that the kitchen could have and
and I have probabilities of them and and
I let the system evolve then if the
kitchen is a closed system and if the
laws of physics are what a physicists
would call unitary but we can call time
reversible like if we could run the
clock forward and backward in those
deterministic great deterministic yeah
then that entropy will be conserved that
that is there's no second law of entropy
increase
there's just entropy is a fixed quantity
because the information you have about
the system remains the same the
information remains the same because it
can't go away if it did you would never
be able to get back that information by
just evolving the laws of physics back
so so that these two notions of entropy
one of them tells you that information
in your description of something is
preserved if you keep track of it by
carefully evolving the laws of physics
the other tells you that the information
that you have about us the sort of
description that you have about a system
about its dynamics in terms of these
different collections these
coarse-grained description that you have
that sort of goes away in the sense that
the entropy increases the system gets
more and more generic unavoidably and
you're kind of handle on the system
disappears and that that's the second
law of thermodynamics in action and it's
and it's sort of inevitable in the sense
that it's inevitable to the degree that
the variables that these the smearing
that you want to do as a as a kind of
big coarse-grained macroscopic observer
is something that the fundamental laws
of the that are evolving the state of
the universe don't care about right
there those laws are very simple they
don't know anything about clean and
messy kitchen yeah and because they know
nothing about each other they sort of
inevitably have to drive you to these
more and more generic states and entropy
increases so so it's I think it's
important to distinguish those two
although there are relations that we
could go into but I'm not sure that it's
that it's worthwhile and it's that
second one
[Music]
is the thing that is sorry my switch the
second way which is the first one in
which is the second one well yeah yeah
so it's it's the it's the generic miss
one yeah the disorder one that is
increasing even while in some sense if
there were a a entropy of the universe
in terms of the probabilities of its
states that would just be sitting there
information will be preserved so there's
a sense in which the early universe was
very orderly and that's what we mean
when we say that it was low entropy so
what is the relationship there then with
information because you said that
there's this large amount of information
we had right so so again I think if you
think of the the orderliness you can
also think of a a gap between how
disorderly something could be and how
disorderly it is right now and call that
order or or specificity or something and
that is the thing that is going away as
the universe ages there as any physical
system ages as entropy increases and so
the universe was endowed with a
tremendous amount of that whatever that
you want to call that order at the
beginning and we know that because we've
watched that order kind of decay away as
the second law has unfolded through the
history of the universe there are lots
of processes that we can see that are
sort of using up that order and stars
and star shine or easia things clumped
together grass grows people metabolize
stuff so there's this chain you can see
from that early order to clumping stars
star light plants people eating it and
metabolizing it and ultimately we're
using that that sort of primordial store
of order every time we eat something and
that eating allows us to stay out of
going to equilibrium as a nice close
physical system our our tendency if just
left to our own devices would be to go
to higher entropy that is very bad for a
living system to go dramatically higher
entropy than it is so we have to
maintain this the sort of entropy that
we have and we do that by ingesting
stuff
that has information content to it and
giving off waste that has much less
information or much more entropy off
into our environment and so we stay kind
of we're not a closest and we're kind of
open system but we stay in sort of a
enduring macroscopic configuration that
we call a living thing
yeah the physics wanting us to to sort
of go to higher entropy I think there's
something confusing to me because I do
think I understand this stuff but you're
you're very properly drawing a
distinction between the sort of
information way of thinking about
entropy and the disorderliness way of
thinking about entropy but then you say
the universe is low entropy early times
in the messiness sense and that's useful
for life existing but then you you
switch to saying well we ingest high
information foods I think we should have
said high order foods okay good then it
doesn't something everything makes sense
again good yes so yeah so this is worth
emphasising that life itself is a
process of that both relies on and and
assists with the tendency of the
universe to increase in its
disorderliness yes I so I think it's
both so if you had no entropy increase I
think you wouldn't have living systems
in the sense that the things that we
actually do the metabolism that we do
are all and all entropy increasing
processes but I also think it's fair to
say that a lot of what metabolism is
doing is maintaining kind of homeostasis
in the face of this tendency to go to
disorder and and the only way to do that
is to embed ourselves in a larger
orderly system and kind of consume some
of that order in order to maintain that
homeostasis and that's largely orderly
system is the sunlight and the biosphere
and the universe beyond that that has
much more ordered has a big reservoir of
order to it that we are allowed to make
use of would you say that this suggests
a kind of anthropic explanation for why
the early universe had
entropy because without that low entropy
we wouldn't be here talking about it
that's certainly true whether that's an
explanation or not I think is a longer
discussion but yes I think I think it's
it's probably true that if you just had
an equilibrium universe in sort of the
most generic state that you wouldn't
have there's a lot of words to hedge
here for reasons that I think you well
understand that
you certainly wouldn't have a world like
we experienced it I would say and I
think that's mostly true at the same
time there there's a lot of tricky
business to entropy for in the following
sense so and and and this has to do with
what we might call indexical information
and so that is so suppose you have a
bunch of ants you know in a in a big ant
farm or something
now you could describe properties of
these ants like you know they tend to
have this sort of speed walking around
they they tend to have this much food in
their stomachs or whatever statistical
properties of the ants and you could
then attribute an entropy that was
connected to those statistical
properties and you could say that you
know here's how much information we have
about this big collection of ants all
right and that would be some amount of
information but now suppose you pick out
a particular ant so now you don't have a
bunch of like vague statistical
distributions you have particular
properties of it and so that there's a
lot more information associated with
that particular ant than there is with a
whole group of ants because the whole
group of ants has statistics which are
more vague an individual ant has very
precise numbers so it's a lot more
uncertainty with the group yeah now
what's the weird thing is you take a
bunch of ants each of which has lots of
information associated with it you put
them all together and you get something
without much information associated with
it so so
this is a strange thing about
information it's not quite additive in
that sense you take a whole bunch of
individual high information things and
put them together and you get something
that is lower information and and
similarly you can imagine I mean because
you forgot something right because you
because you because you forget yes yes
because you because you didn't keep
track of so if you if your collection of
ants was your full description of each
individual ant then you'd still have all
that information but once you start to
treat it as a collection you lose that
yeah so now this the information that we
have
so as we like as I individually look out
into the universe there's a particular
point of view that I have and associated
with that or a bunch of very particular
things about the universe there's a
particular room that I'm in the
particular planet that I'm on in a
particular galaxy and so on so that's a
whole bunch of information that is
associated with me right if I take the
description of the universe as a whole
it's not clear that that information is
still there what the universe as a whole
might have are things like how many
planets there tend to be around a star
and how many stars there are in a
typical galaxy and things like that so
you can imagine that the universe as a
whole might actually have very little
information content because all it
really has are statistics whereas when I
take a particular view of the universe
my view there's a ton of information
associated with that sure and and that
is both kind of sort of clear and also
weirdly paradoxical because it also has
that feeling of creating a whole bunch
of information from nowhere right where
did it come from
it just came from being me like and
that's very easy to do yeah like it
almost no effort so I think you know
when when I think about the ultimate
origin of the sort of information in the
universe and is there a cheat similar to
the cheat that that we got in creating
the origin of the matter that's sort of
where I look like is there a way in
which we can get a whole lot of
information for free even though in from
another standpoint it's
like there really isn't much information
and so I think it's some level that's
true but I don't think that that's an
explanation at the moment for for where
the information of the universe comes
from but if if there were an explanation
I think that might be some aspect of it
I mean my answer would have been that
the entropy of the early universe was
way lower than it ever needed to be for
any simple anthropic argument but so
this comes in to the idea that if you
were in equilibrium if you if the
universe was just the cosmological
equivalent of a big box of gas at high
entropy there could be fluctuations
right I've heard people talk about this
idea of fluctuating into a lonely brain
floating in the cosmos the pole thought
we agreed we weren't going to talk about
that no you agreed on it you actually to
be very very technical you said you were
happy to talk about is just annoying so
I took that as an assent but you know we
we're providing a service here at
mindscape we know that people out there
in the audience have heard of Boltzmann
brains if you think it's annoying and
shouldn't it be a big part of the
science then please tell us why but
first please tell us what the idea is
no it's annoying it's annoying on on
multiple levels and part of annoying is
of course interesting I mean I should
specify when I say something is knowing
that a lot of the projects that I've
worked on and found most fruitful in my
career have been born of being very
annoyed at something so this is not
necessarily a negative thing ultimately
and Boltzmann brains are one of those
things that I think almost anyone who
thinks about them would agree that
they're annoying yet also provocative
interest interesting and so the notion
here is that if you if you imagine a
system that is in equilibrium the
statement was that system is boring it's
kind of information free it just sits
there all of its properties are come
follow from the fact that it's just in
equilibrium and yet we also know if we
think about the kitchen that the kitchen
we'll just stay messy essentially
forever but if you if you let your kid
and mess around in the kitchen long
enough they might
we clean something up you know and and
it might go down and entropy a little
bit and so any equilibrium system is
like this it will from time to time sort
of accidentally wander into a lower
entropy more ordered state and so you
can you can imagine saying well yes we
live in an orderly universe but maybe it
just wandered into that orderly state so
there's really no mystery there we just
the universe is in equilibrium but
occasionally wanders into an orderly
state and we find ourself in one of
those orderly states and so the
Boltzmann brain argument is is sort of
pointing out the flaw in the sort of
reasoning which is essentially that the
universe that we actually see and and
infer is out there using science and
other means is way way way way WAY lower
entropy that is a much much bigger
fluctuation if it were one then is
actually then is necessary to kind of
account for our just first-person
experience of existing as a thinking
being all that it would take to exist as
a thinking being is like a single brain
or some simple system not simple some
incredibly complex but small on a cosmic
scale system like a brain it could think
oh here I am for a moment and in fact it
could it could account for any set of
first person like perceptions that you
might imagine you can you can imagine a
physical system that would have that set
of perceptions and whatever that is like
I see a galaxy I see the Cosmic
Microwave Background all of that could
have rain whatever those things whatever
you postulate this is the data that I
want to explain you can imagine as very
very small system like a brain that
would observe that data but then nothing
more interesting so after a very short
time it would the that systems
experience would very radically diverge
from the experience that we have in the
world as being you know has having
originated in a sensible cosmology like
we do so now people's viewpoints of this
vary a little bit some people would say
you know the assumption that we're a
Boltzmann brain because it makes a
prediction which
immediately falsified by the fact that
you know the universe goes on and
doesn't assemble into chaos or something
that's one point of view you can also
say something like if we're really a
Boltzmann brain then we don't know
anything and our we can't trust our
reasoning we can't trust our perceptions
we can't trust anything so that's sort
of just a self undermining way of
thinking like it's not a consistent
thing to think because there's no reason
to even trust that my memory of two
seconds ago when I was talking has
anything any reality to it so so I think
that but what people agree is is agree
on I think is that if you're that
entropy fluctuation downward simply is
not kind of a viable explanation for how
we found ourselves in the low entropy
state we find ourselves in at least I'm
sorry itself yes oh sorry not that not
just that we're not individually
Boltzmann brains or something like that
but we don't live in a Boltzmann
universe right right so the Boltzmann
brain is really just a kind of reductio
ad absurdum for thinking that the
universe as a whole fluctuated down into
a low entropy state right and I think it
actually is probably would be a lot less
confusing not to talk about brains but
just to talk about the universe and then
there'd probably be a lot less arguments
but probably it's a fun it's a fun thing
yeah but so what we're just to leave us
so we agree that life what you and I
think of as life you know a certain
process going on in a complex system
here on earth maybe elsewhere relies on
the fact that we live in this very low
entropy universe where entropy is
increasing a little bit right that's
where we get food from and that's how we
make interesting things it may or may
not go on forever I would say it can't
go on forever I think you eventually
reach high entropy you want to be more
cautious about that I can't really argue
with that
we don't know why it started low in the
very very early universe so these are
facts or very solid arguments what did
they teach us about cosmology I mean
what are they what are the lessons that
we can draw for how we should be
thinking
about the universe and what the job of
professional cosmologists should be well
if that's an interesting question I
think the I'm in one step I think is is
to ask even if we don't get like a full
answer to where did the information come
from or where why did we start in low
entropy we might get a sort of partial
answer in the same way that we got at
least a partial answer to where did all
this stuff come from so we didn't talk
much about inflation although we we we
talked about it without naming it
inflation inflation is the is a vacuum
energy dominated early phase of the
universe that would would be the thing
that the the name for the process where
all of the stuff came from by
reproducing lots of space full of energy
inflation also does sort of things on
the entropy front which are a little bit
more controversial but what I think it
uncontroversially does is create a lot
of region of space which is which looks
like low entropy as long as you don't
worry about the space-time degrees of
freedom so if you just think about the
matter that is in space-time what
inflation does is make a nice big
uniform kind of chemically simple state
of matter that is very very low entropy
and that is the the state from which you
can generate lots of order that that
comes later in the form of stars and
interesting chemistry and and all of
that stuff so I think there's a sense in
which inflation is a is a crucial
ingredient in sort of understanding how
information and its sort of generation
or order and its generation and usage
kind of actually happened could have
happened in the universe without
necessarily being like an ultimate
answer to the question of where did all
the order come from I think that that's
a much trickier thing to assess with
inflation as a good Bayesian what is
your percentage chance that what is your
prior that inflation actually happened
in the early
82% all right I'm down at like 50
something percent I'm more skeptical
than you are you know I think that you
alluded to this very quickly but maybe
for the listeners out there we should
emphasize inflation does seem to create
the kind of universe that we live in but
only at the cost of assuming a very very
low entropy condition to begin inflation
in the first place so you've pushed the
mystery back more than solving it you've
pushed the business back though I would
claim that we don't really know how to
specify what the entropy of the
space-time you know when you say
inflation had to be a very very low
entropy state I think we don't quite
know how to actually rigorously define
that entropy that would be low well if
you think that it was low entropy at the
end of inflation and you didn't think
that entropy magically went down you
must think that it was even lower before
inflation right so we're assuming that
there is a thing called entropy and that
it still has a second law and and
therefore like it inevitably had to be
lower earlier that's that's all you can
ever get but but if that's the
assumption you sort of you're never
gonna get out of the mystery so oh I
think you can well yeah yeah so so if
you were yes if you assume that that the
the information the universe is simply
endowed with an infinite amount of order
then then it's true that no matter how
much you use up there's still an
infinite amount left but so whether that
is a satisfactory explanation is
probably a longer conversation for
another time that would be that would be
great fun to have but we do both agree
that this is a big puzzle for cosmology
and I think that you know to help our
non experts out there we're in the
minority in some sense right this is not
one of the questions that most working
cosmologists would bring up as one of
the big puzzles there it's true but I
think I can give good
I think it's vastly underappreciated in
that sense because it really is the yeah
ultimate question of where everything
comes from
in a way because everything in a large
sense I think is made up of this order
you know all of the the things that we
describe all the stars and planets and
things the thing that makes them all
possible is this reservoir of order that
we inherit from the early universe
otherwise everything would be just be
super
whirring and so if this growth of
entropy or this growth of order
throughout cosmic history is driving
every interesting process that everybody
cares about so till the next it's a
vastly underappreciated and super
important topic as I'm sure you would
agree having spent lots of time thinking
about it but it's true that it's it's
brushed under the rug in comparison to I
would say much more prosaic concerns and
in some sense that that are still
interesting but but aren't yeah I agree
that it's just we're a minority but we
shouldn't be everybody should be
worrying about no we're totally right
that's that we can agree on two we
haven't used the phrased yet but we've
been talking about the increase of
entropy and and disorderliness and what
we usually say is that defines the arrow
of time or at least the throat
thermodynamic arrow of time the
difference between past and future and
as you just said I think maybe it's it's
worth sort of elaborating on this idea
this fact that entropy is increasing
really underlies all of the
interestingness of our lives right I
mean that's it's hard to overemphasize
how important this is so things like
memory cause and effect free well
they're all ultimately traceable in some
sense to the fact that entropy is
increasing all around us I can only
agree yes well you can do more you could
do more I can I can say more about that
well in the in the following sense like
I I do this myself like I saved those
statements but because I believe that
they're true but I think that just as
cosmologists haven't focused on why
their early universe had a low entropy
enough the rest of the world hasn't
focused enough quite on elaborating how
that increase of entropy over time gives
rise to all of these different phenomena
yeah I agree and I think the everything
you know in some sense everything that
happens has this character to it in that
happening is sort of a change in
something like something there was one
state and then there was a different one
and when everything if you imagine
everything being either an equilibrium
or in the description where the entropy
was not changing then there's a sense in
which nothing is really happening in
that you know you can just run the clock
forward and backward and you can't
really like distinguish the later thing
from the earlier one like everything
that's in the later one is in the
earlier one and vice versa the fact that
there's something new or that there's
something lost there you're talking
about not the fundamental dynamics of
the system not the the sort of unitary
dynamics but you're talking in terms of
a different level of description of the
system that's happening in these
coarse-grained or macroscopic or
something variables which is the arena
in which the second law is operating and
which in from and in which you can talk
about information changing or going away
or being generated in some sense and I
think that's the the world or that's
actually many worlds like many different
levels of description which are the
world that we actually inhabit so so
anything that we talk about as where
we're using a level description that
isn't like the wave function of the
universe is evolving according to - yeah
Schrodinger's equation any other way
that we describe things we're talking
about it in this more coarse-grained way
in which the the tendency of that sort
of the relationship between that
description of the world and the
fundament you know the wave function
description of the world is absolutely
it's sort of central and that is the
second law of thermodynamics that like
the the tension between those two
descriptions that is driving entropy
increase is sort of responsible for
everything it's responsible for you know
that there is a future in a past that
are different that you can't go back in
time and just tell what happened in the
past that you predict the future and you
remember the past that their records all
of these things that just are our
everyday moment-to-moment existence just
are inexorably associated with that
second law and and and I and I think
you're right that
I too you know say those words while
appreciating that to actually you know
if pressed on how exactly you know is it
that we get records of the past and only
predictions of the future it's very very
hard to pin down in concrete terms or
how is it that we can cause the future
and remember the past and not vice versa
you know actually formally carefully
specifying those things is enormous ly
subtle to do and I think that project is
you know people think about that but is
largely undone in my book well your
organization gave me a grant to think
about it so I do have a paper coming out
that I think you'll be very well
speaking of which so that we have this
situation that you described very
eloquently where the universe makes
sense in the sense that there are laws
right there are rules it's not just
crazy chaos breaking out all the time
but there are these looming questions
like why does universe exist at all why
does it have a specifically low entropy
in the beginning do these features of
the universe as we see it lend credence
to the idea that maybe we all just live
in a computer simulation not in a
naturally forming universe sure why they
which features would lend credence to us
being in a simulation well you know you
we have to need to sorry we need to
attribute some psychology to our
simulators and you know maybe they're
just starting from some simple initial
conditions and seeing what happens and
we end up as part of the backwash yeah I
guess I
I guess I don't see it as sort of
evidence either way I think well what do
you think of the argument in general I
mean let me not be so specifically
provocative in that direction
well there are simulate so there there
are a bunch of different things that you
might call a simulation argument some of
which I think are total nonsense and
some of which are both are only somewhat
nonsense but also very hard to rule out
so there's one species of thing that
says you know given given enough
technology you know in
200 or something years we will be able
to run simulations of say what happened
in the second half of the 20th century
on earth and and historians will be
delighted with this because then they
can go back and I think about what what
would have happened if the you know
Nazis had won war and all kinds of
interesting counterfactuals and things
like that and so and these simulations
will be so detailed that they'll have to
simulate you know down to the the neuron
level of the beings in them to get to
get the simulations right and so if we
assume that the beings in those
simulations are self-aware just like we
are
then then you end up in this situation
where they're all these simulations
being done of all these beings and so
why aren't we one of those beings and
one of those simulations that will be
run in our future okay so this is this
is something that is called the
simulation argument and it was made
formulated in this kind of way by Nick
Bostrom I'm profoundly profoundly
skeptical of this argument in that I
think I think it will turn out that in
order to simulate even a bacterium in a
in a useful sense will turn out to be
impossible given the computational
resources of the universe and that the
only way to really simulate a bacterium
will be to create a physical system that
is like isomorphic to a bacterium line a
bacteria so this will just not be an
exciting thing to do like yes if you're
super civilization you can make lots of
versions of Earth and see how things
played out but you don't get anything
for free you'll be creating lots of
earths and okay so so I guess I just
find that version of the argument not
compelling on the other hand there you
can sort of ask if the universe you know
if you think ask what is the universe
really made of and your answer is first
like well it's made of atoms which are
made of you know subatomic particles
fine but if you ask what are those
particles then things start to get a
little bit more slippery their
excitations of a quantum field or
they're sort of things that are pointed
to by a wave function what is a quantum
field made of well a quantum field is
like made of the ability to create
particles it gets very circular yeah and
you ask what is a wavefunction it's a
description of where particles will be
when you measure them 9 another these
have a sort of tangibility to them and
they have more like a feeling of an
information theoretic thing and this
leads you you know if you think about
this a long time you sort of feel like
well ultimately the the universe maybe
is a sort of informational entity and
then you start to think well what does
that mean you know if if who's got the
information what is it like the the
floor kind of drops out from under you a
little bit when you start to think along
those lines and then if you think you
know the universe is sort of this
information thing could it could it be
that that information is in some larger
setting it's a simulation and some super
duper computer who knows so I I think
it's a rank speculation after that point
but I think the the thing that gets you
there to think what is some of the
fundamental like constitution of reality
I think we've actually shed a lot of
interesting light on that and it's just
just much much weirder and kind of
disquieting than you could imagine when
you think of though when you're so used
to thinking of the universe is made of
little bits of stuff yeah well this goes
back to where we started right in the
fact that if you do science well it
should be a little discomforting at the
end of the day concede that we've been
very we talked about the big picture of
the whole universe and where it comes
from what that implies and how that life
can exist in it but you've also been
more practical in your concerns about
the universe I mean you you seem to
every couple years start a new
organization of some sort why are you
share with the listeners like some of
the various organizations that you've
had your fingers in the pies of yes so
you mentioned one the foundational
questions Institute and yeah and this is
an organization that that was born of
the desire to
to have more of the type of fun that
we've been having here getting people
together to talk about the really big
questions and and also seeing if we can
give other people give people money you
know in research funding and
institutional support and so on to do
that and that's been on since 2006 let
me just you know mention out there for
the world that it's a wonderful thing
precisely because some of these
questions are perhaps some of the most
interesting and fun questions you can
ask in science but it can be hard to get
funding for them because they can fall
between the disciplinary cracks right or
they seem a little bit too
pie-in-the-sky and foundational
questions Institute has done a great job
of stepping in and trying to support
some of these efforts despite that yeah
yeah I thank you and and I I just agreed
for example this this incredibly
important question of where all the
order in the universe came from it is
very difficult to get you know an NSF
grant on that question right it's sort
of too big and and so on so that's one
organization then there was a sort of
spin off of that that happened I think
largely because a certain constituency
of people in that organization including
max tegmark and myself taking the long
term view of the universe which you have
to do as a cosmologists you sort of
realize well we don't just have to think
about the past 20 years of the next 10
or 15 years we can think on larger
scales as as you know cosmologists and
physicists what what is the world and
society gonna look like in a thousand
years or a million or a billion and once
you start thinking about that it kind of
reconfigures some of the questions that
you're thinking about like is it really
realistic to think that a thousand years
from now for example we're not going to
have built machines smarter than us or
we're not going to have been able to
change our like our biological makeup to
be something radically different if we
want to and so so you well you can ask
are we gonna make machines smarter than
us in the next 10 years or 15 years and
and have lots of debate about that or 20
or 30 or 40 in a thousand we're gonna do
it right so it's just
of when and that gets you just thinking
about what is that long-term future look
like then what do we want to have happen
do we want to replace ourselves with
with machines do we want to have them be
around even though they're they're
smarter than us do we want to make
ourselves smarter you say you can you
can think of all these long-term
questions that are cited kind of science
fictiony but also I think based in you
know if at least some species of science
fiction are based in real science and
there are things that you can say about
them based on the physics that we do
know and I think one thing that that
raft of thinking made clear to us was
that we're we're in an incredibly vital
time in sort of the next 50 years or so
in that it seems quite plausible that if
we kind of continue for the next say
fifty or a hundred years as we have been
technological increase more capability
ability to do you know just put in
practice a lot of things that we want to
do
medically information technology space
we can move out into space we there's a
good chance that if we make it through
the next hundred years we could make it
through the next thousand or million or
billion if we can get off the planet and
we can get our back together in various
ways on the other hand there's a very
good chance that we can just kill
ourselves off in the next 50 years and
this vast vast amount of awesome stuff
that might otherwise have happened is
just going to be curtailed because
somebody thought you know a glint off
some clouds was a nuclear missile and
it's all over right so that would be
just sort of an unbelievable tragedy and
anything that you can do to reduce the
probability of that sort of tragedy
happening is really really high-impact
if you look at that big picture and so I
think that convinced some of us that if
you realize that something is incredibly
high impact and important you might want
to do a little bit of it so we don't go
too far out on a limb there yeah yeah
well you don't have to but but it is
motivating so so we we started this new
organization called the future of life
Institute that is
concerned with that question essentially
given these existing like nuclear or
coming very high-powered transformative
technologies in biotech and artificial
intelligence and so on what are the
things that we should be thinking about
however we can figure it out to increase
the probability of things going well or
at least decently and decrease the
probability of catastrophe it's kind of
that simple but figuring out what
exactly those things are and how to do
them you know that that's the rub so
that that's what is what we have been
thinking about I mean is it so well how
do you do it what does it give us an
example project or effort that you would
do so so it's a lot of effort that we
put in so far has been on artificial
intelligence and starting to create a
field of research that takes seriously
the idea that artificial intelligence
could possibly have a downside as well
as an upside and that if if we really
take seriously the idea that AI could
succeed you know in its in its goal of
making things that are broadly
intelligent in the human sort of sense
or or more then that opens up a rather
large can of worms what what is the
world actually look like what is a
scenario in which there are lots of
entities that are more capable
intellectually than people look like and
is that a you know how can we imagine a
world in which that is the case and
where we're happy and what does that
world look like or can't we and then we
better rethink some things if we're
trying to accomplish something that
we're we can't imagine it turning out
well so I think that sort of a long
that's a vague question but there are a
lot of very specific research questions
in machine learning and AI and adjoining
fields where you can ask like what does
it mean to make a machine learning or AI
system that is robust what does it mean
to make one that will continue to do the
things that we wanted to do and rather
than following say what we tell it to do
but in ways that we are very unhappy
with how it actually accomplishes those
things so this is a very long
conversation but but sure funding like
actual scientific technical research on
how to do artificial intelligence safety
safely is one of the crucial things that
I think we've been working on I mean how
would excuse me how would you just
personally rank the risk of AI alongs
tied alongside such things as nuclear
war or global climate catastrophe as
things we should be worrying about it
depends on what sort of worry so I think
climate change is like like obviously
happening and going to happen is going
to be a catastrophe at some level almost
certainly in my view and and so so it's
obviously worth worrying about
at the same time I don't think climate
change is going to be as catastrophic as
a nuclear war would be if we had one I
think that's fairly clear but is very
high probability a nuclear war is just
disquieting ly highly probable also
being rather relatively low you know a
percent or something per year which is
terrifying but yeah but we've learned to
live with somehow AI I think is
different in the sense that I attribute
quite low probability to like or being a
breakthrough in AI next week and
suddenly a self-aware computer like
takes over the world and kills us all
like Anna Terminator you know this is
this is very sort of sensationalistic
and not worth putting a lot of thought
into but at the same time you know if it
given that we have a massive investment
in artificial intelligence
you know there's now a thousand or so
really really excellent scientists
working at google deepmind explicitly
working on developing artificial general
intelligence this is just many many many
many many more really smart people than
we're doing at 10 years ago
yeah and I don't want to bet against the
concerted efforts of many many many
really smart people for decades so so I
think that is that is convinced me that
it's not going to be hundreds of
most likely that the probability
distribution is in the decades you know
and not in the not in the long long term
future and that I think so
so the probability you know that doesn't
necessarily mean it's a catastrophe but
I think it does mean a sort of phase
change for civilization when we when we
succeed in bringing something into being
that is as capable as us and as general
is us and you know replicatable and all
those things there is no way that things
are just going to be business as usual
yeah and and I think we just better be
thinking pretty hard about that because
it may not be that that far away well
okay good you've given us things to
think about both on the cosmic scale and
the more near-term scale
why don't you play us out with another
Cohen from your book is there a
particular good one that would serve as
an epilogue for the conversation let's
see yeah it's good to have a sacred text
you can read from for any sermon when
you're asked okay so these are a couple
of characters that have been introduced
earlier in the book that are historical
people
yaagh you Munenori and tatyana ho or
swordsman in the early 17th century in
japan and they're sitting at a game of
go when you enter they ignore you as you
watch them you go increasingly uneasy as
you realize they are breaking the rules
or at least not play and go during a
momentary lapse in the rooms focus you
ask what is this game that you're
playing that is for you to understand
replies so ho you almost think you see
Munenori smile which always signals
danger the game wears on each move
taking longer than the last try as you
might just when you think you understand
the rules the played stone proves you
wrong at last so who concedes I have no
move Munenori nods a bow after a time so
ho speaks sometime I would like to hear
the rules that you played in the end
you're surprised you didn't know the
rules Munenori turns toward you
neither knew the rules in advance so is
the world
this makes me want to say things but I
think it'd be more appropriate if we
just called it there and let ourselves
contemplate what that all means all
right Anthony gear 8 thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast thanks
for having us tremendous one I take care
bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]